i
[Música]
la casa blanca defendió al presidente
joe biden después de que durante una
entrevista asegurara que cree que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin es un
asesino moscú que exige explicaciones
llamó a consultas a su embajador en
washington el curso de bailén de no
querer mejorar las relaciones con rusia
preocupante la situación epidemiológica
en américa latina' por cuenta del hobbit
19 donde los ojos siguen puestos sobre
brasil que volvió a registrar un récord
de contagios con más de 90 mil casos y
sobrepasó los 5.000 fallecidos en las
últimas 48 horas colombia llegó al
millón de vacunados y a pesar de su
avanzado proceso de inmunización chile
registra alza en hospitalizaciones
agentes de policía y manifestantes
paraguayos se enfrentaron en las afueras
del congreso en la capital asunción
luego de que la cámara de diputados
rechazara el pedido de juicio político
contra el presidente mario abdo benítez
por mal desempeño en la pandemia de
coronavirus al menos cinco personas
fueron detenidas
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 sino blanco como siempre un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos rusia
calificó como sin precedentes los
comentarios del presidente
estadounidense yo vaya en los que
aseguró creer que vladimir putin es un
asesino para moscú tales declaraciones
demuestran que el líder de la casa
blanca no tiene intención alguna de
enmendar las ya tensas relaciones entre
los dos países por ahora putin no tiene
planeado reunirse con su embajador ruso
en washington que fue llamado consultas
tras el incidente diplomático
una relación tensa que tomó otro gélido
giro el miércoles rusia convocó al
embajador de eeuu anatoli antónov de
vuelta a moscú tras las declaraciones
del presidente estadounidense joe biden
sobre su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
que es un asesino
software así que qué precio debe pagar
por expresión que va a pagar lo verás
frontur ver los comentarios de by the
han hechos en una entrevista con el vice
news se produjeron a raíz de un informe
desclasificado de la inteligencia de
eeuu que determinó que putin autorizó
influencias para ayudar a donald trump
en las elecciones presidenciales del
pasado noviembre
moscú ha rechazado las conclusiones por
considerarlas infundadas rusia no tiene
nada que ver con ninguna campaña contra
ningún candidato
en este sentido decimos que este informe
es erróneo no tiene absolutamente ningún
fundamento ni ninguna prueba sin embargo
el kremlin subrayó su deseo de evitar un
deterioro irreversible de las relaciones
por su parte las críticas de la
administración trampa rusia marcan un
claro alejamiento de la firma de
posición de choam para decir algo
negativo del presidente ruso
nuestra relación se verá diferente será
diferente alzaremos la voz en aquellos
temas que nos conciernen son y los rusos
tendrán que rendir cuentas por las
acciones que han tomado en los últimos
comentarios de biden añaden
especulaciones sobre si washington
impondrá nuevas sanciones a moscú pronto
esto después de imponerlas a cuatro
altos funcionarios rusos por el
envenenamiento y posterior
encarcelamiento del crítico opositor
alexéi navalni
en 324 hacemos un repaso a la situación
de latinoamérica en donde los ojos
siguen puestos sobre brasil es gigante
sudamericano volvió a registrar el
miércoles un récord de contagios con más
de 90.000 casos mientras tanto colombia
llegó al millón de vacunados y en chile
aunque esta nación es considerada como
un ejemplo por el número de antídotos
que ha aplicado preocupan el alza en las
hospitalizaciones juan rubiales tiene el
informe
brasil parece no ver la luz al final del
túnel ningún otro país de américa
registra tantos contagios como esta
nación el miércoles se contabilizaron
más de 90 mil casos en las últimas 48
horas hubo más de 5000 fallecidos además
preocupa la ocupación hospitalaria y
aunque el presidente de yair bolsonaro
sigue insistiendo en no respetar el
distanciamiento social su designado un
nuevo ministro de salud parece tener
otro mensaje
podemos reducir el impacto de los
fallecidos con dos puntos primero con
políticas de distanciamiento social que
permitan una reducción de la circulación
del virus y segundo con una mejoría en
la capacidad de asistencia de nuestros
servicios hospital han iniciado dos
nosos servicios hospitalarios el país
vecino colombia registra en contraste
cifras diarias a la baja de contagios y
fallecidos y ahora con un aliciente en
su plan de vacunación el miércoles se
alcanzó el millón de inoculaciones
todos como equipo estamos demostrando
que la vacunación masiva es la mejor
política de la vida en estos momentos de
pandemia a nivel regional chile es el
país que lidera las vacunaciones con más
del 25 por ciento de su población con al
menos una dosis aplicada pero la
ocupación de las ucis hace saltar las
alarmas
ahora mismo hay más de 3000 de estas
camas ocupadas la cifra más alta en toda
la pandemia hay que mantenerse alerta y
desde perú lo refrendan el gobierno
anunció la prohibición de los viajes por
tierra y aire para los próximos días
festivos entre el 1 y el 4 de abril en
semana santa para frenar una pandemia
que en este territorio deja cerca de
50.000 muertos y casi un millón y medio
de contagios
y seguimos en nuestra región vamos hasta
paraguay donde anoche se vivieron
protestas que derivaron en choques entre
la policía y manifestantes que
rechazaban la decisión de la cámara de
diputados de no llevar a juicio político
al presidente mario abdo benítez por su
manejo de la pandemia al menos cinco
personas fueron detenidas los grupos
ciudadanos que convocaron estas
movilizaciones señalaron que seguirán en
las calles hasta que el mandatario
abandone su cargo
la iniciativa de juicio político fue
rechazada con 42 votos en contra 36 a
favor y dos ausencias paraguay atraviesa
una segunda ola de la pandemia tras un
incremento de casos que provocó la
declaración de alerta roja sanitaria y
restricciones a la circulación nocturna
y también la suspensión temporal de las
clases presenciales a una situación que
no nos sorprende de parte del partido
colorado es una manera de articular es
una mafia organizada camuflada como
partido político que siempre entre su
base por lo menos de facto está defender
el intereses cupulares
lo que va a pasar en el pueblo marito ya
no tiene gobernabilidad no puede salir
más de sus casas ni de donde sea
vamos ahora hasta países bajos donde el
conservador lumbar
rutte iniciará diálogos con los
diferentes partidos políticos después de
que las proyecciones del conteo de votos
en las elecciones legislativas
aseguraron una cuarta victoria
consecutiva a su partido el vvd con más
de 60% de los votos escrutados el
partido de reuters se quedaría con 36 de
250 escaños de la cámara baja su
victoria es vista como un respaldo de la
ciudadanía a su manejo de la pandemia
según rutte una nueva coalición con el
partido de izquierda del d66 que terminó
en el segundo lugar sería obvia el
partido de la libertad de extrema
derecha fue el gran perdedor en estos
comicios
y tras 18 días sin noticias este
miércoles se informó sobre la muerte del
presidente de tanzania
jona magaluf maga full y su
fallecimiento se produjo por la
enfermedad cardíaca que le estaba
haciendo tratadas desde hacía varios
años el mandatario se caracterizó por
desestimar la gravedad del coi 19
convocando a los tanzanos a rezar para
superar la enfermedad
el presidente de tanzania john mcfall y
murió este miércoles en dar es salaam la
capital económica del país africano
el mandatario de 61 años falleció tras
padecer una enfermedad cardíaca con la
que lidiaba desde años atrás la
vicepresidenta
samia zulú informó sobre el deceso
ciudadanos lamento informarles que hoy
17 de marzo de 2021 a las seis de la
tarde perdimos a nuestro valiente líder
el presidente de tanzania el honorable
young mago falling full y mago full y un
negacionista del coi 19 había despertado
sospechas por su desaparición de la
escena pública desde el pasado 27 de
febrero cuando se le vio por última vez
en la posesión de su jefe de gabinete
por este motivo la oposición promovió
rumores en torno a un posible contagio
de coronavirus sin confirmarse nada de
manera oficial al principio de la
pandemia el presidente desestimó la
gravedad de la enfermedad invitando a
los ciudadanos a rezar por el bienestar
colectivo
debido a esta negación del gobierno se
desconoce la situación sanitaria de
tanzania desde abril de 2020
no tengan miedo y no se dejen intimidar
por el coronavirus sigamos trabajando
dios está con nosotros y nos salvará la
corona
vago full y casado y padre de tres hijos
fue elegido presidente en octubre de
desde entonces se caracterizó por su
lucha contra la corrupción y sus
políticas de línea dura sin embargo su
imagen se vio afectada por la censura a
medios de comunicación y por denuncias
de acoso a sus detractores políticos en
el parlamento
y recordemos nuestra página web france24
puntocom para que siempre esté conectado
con nosotros estamos saturando la
situación sanitaria en brásil con un
nuevo récord de contagios diarios con
más de 90 mil contagios y además 5 mil
muertos en las últimas 48 horas todo
esto y mucho más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúa con nosotros muy
buen día para todos
[Música]
bien